todos en este vídeo se hicieron la
prueba kobe 19 antes de la filmación que
hiciste poco en el parto
yo tenía tanto miedo de hacerme popó en
el parto así que le dije a mi novio si
lo hago no me digas porque estaré muy
apenada le pedimos a la audiencia que
enviara a sus preguntas sexuales más
íntimas vergonzosas y picantes para que
extraños las respondieran basándose en
sus experiencias
educación sexual el embarazo tu embarazo
fue planeado absolutamente no de hecho
si lo fue algo así nos sentamos a hablar
al respecto como
oye quieres tener un bebé porque yo
quiero un bebé no teníamos sexo sin
protección sí aunque tome la píldora del
día después luego de 5 horas igual me
embaracé pregunté el porqué a la doctora
y me dijo estabas ovulando y la
ovulación no se puede detener la píldora
evita la ovulación todas las veces
usábamos condones y no sé cómo pasó
siempre hay gente que dice usa
protección yo usaba protección
y aún así me sucedió tu pareja y tú eran
sexualmente activos durante el embarazo
si no porque era soltera no note ninguna
diferencia excepto cuando era mucho más
grande porque eso se debe explorar pero
fue bueno es raro porque usualmente no
soy una persona con un líbido alto y en
el embarazo era bastante activa todo el
tiempo y luego del parto enseguida se
acabó no sé si llegaría a embarazarme
otra vez para averiguar si podría ser
bueno
pero no lo creo no es agradable como fue
el parto y lloré un montón llore como 20
horas seguidas mi parto fue
inesperadamente largo fue de 48 horas
tuvieron que inducir me porque mi fuente
se rompió pero no sentía contracciones y
cuando en realidad tuve no estuvo nada
mal porque él salió en 10 minutos
lo malo vino después como tener que ir
al baño y esas cosas
tuve un desgarre en el momento del parto
así que saturaron por dentro y dolió
todo un mes como mujer negra da miedo
tener que ir al hospital mi mayor miedo
era que yo no iba a tener un parto
nature
parto vaginal no lo hice una cesárea es
una cirugía mayor te hacen una cortada
abierta mueven tus órganos de su lugar
en la actualidad de la mujer promedio ni
siquiera tiene la capacidad de sentarse
en casa por seis semanas tipo tomar y
reposo por cirugía me hicieron una
cesárea de emergencia apenas la recuerdo
sentía que estaba dopada al momento
puede que estés entumecida pero estoy
segura de que pude sentirlas
mi doctor tan profundas dentro de la
cavidad de mi estómago luego la sacaron
y ella lloró hoy es verdad lo que dicen
de es uno de los sonidos más hermosos
luego de eso ya no tanto a la primera
vez la mejor te hiciste popó en el parto
yo tenía tanto miedo de hacerme popó en
el parto así que le dije a mi novio si
lo hago no me digas porque estaré muy
apenada pero no lo hice no lo sé no me
dijeron no me hice popó durante el parto
porque no tuve que pujar sucede que
cuando tienes una cesárea ellos deben
asegurarse de que tú sabes uses el baño
antes de dejar el hospital porque el
proceso de sacar un bebé por cesárea es
es rudo con tus entrañas tuviste alguna
dificultad durante tu embarazo
tuve hipertensión lo usual es que la
presión arterial baje en el embarazo la
mía era lo que llaman normal alta se
mantuvo hasta que fui inducida a las 37
semanas me desmayé un par de veces
estuve bajo el azúcar en la sangre nunca
me había pasado antes en mi embarazo no
tuve ningún tipo de dificultad fue más
bien durante el
que se complicó el ritmo cardíaco de mi
hijo cayó bruscamente mi barriga y
tuvieron que usar un aparato que
succiona para para ayudarme empujar por
qué se tardó mucho en salir pero en
realidad mi embarazo fue muy tranquilo
me encantaba tener la barriga y todo era
muy linda al segundo mes pensé bien esto
me gusta y lo perdí a las 15 semanas fue
en definitiva
una experiencia traumática estaba en
casa y comencé a tener unos dolores
pensé en definitiva algo está mal y
comencé a manchar y luego había mucha
mucha sangre y fui al baño a meterme en
la ducha porque no podía caminar
creo que era más triste que otra cosa la
parte física fue muy dolorosa como
literalmente se sentía como si alguien
estuviese apuñalando mi útero una y otra
vez en toda esta zona llamé a
emergencias y dije algo está mal creo
que perdí a mi bebé me dice quieres que
enviamos a alguien no un bien a nadie no
puedo pagar una ambulancia justo ahora
envían a nadie y ella dijo me quedo en
llamada contigo y dije sí
era una agradable señora sureña
era muy dulce y me acompañó todo el rato
diciéndome que estaría bien que lo malo
pasará y me dijo algo como bien esto
será raro pero debes ir a tu ginecólogo
así que llame es una cita de emergencia
para el día siguiente y tuve que ir para
qué raspada los restos que quedaban
dentro
estuve acostada allí todo el tiempo
avergonzado y triste solo quería ver a
mi mamá
creo que dejar la relación en la que
estaba en el momento que lo hice fue
probablemente lo más sano que he hecho
por mí en mucho tiempo y le tengo mucho
cariño sigo estando muy envuelta en su
vida seguimos siendo muy buenos amigos
creo que es saber que ambos pudimos
avanzar y seguir adelante con nuestras
vidas de una forma más sana me ha
ayudado a superarlo considera este
hacerte un aborto o te habrías hecho un
aborto le dije a mi mamá y respondió
bien déjame gen darte una cita para que
aborte si así fue la mañana de la cita
para abortar le dije que no podría si lo
pensamos serían todas las opciones no y
es porque tenía 26 chica tú te lo
buscaste sé una mujer y te en el baby
decidí hacerme un aborto incluso antes
de embarazarme le envié un mensaje tipo
tenemos que hablar estoy embarazada y me
haré un aborto
y se puso a llorar lo cual está bien
pero recuerdo decirle oye soy la que
está embarazada quiero llorar puedes
consolarme para cada quien es distinto
yo no me avergoncé de mi decisión pero
sigue siendo algo emocional la peor
parte fue una cantidad increíble de
personas afuera de la clínica gritando
me a la cara que me vaya al infierno y
que era una asesina a los 17 años de
verdad es algo que resalta como gran
parte de la experiencia es una locura
fui a planned parenthood en la mañana
recuerdo que me dieron la píldora en un
vaso y bien está segura cuando tomes
esto después de eso no hay vuelta atrás
y les dije sí estoy segura luego fui a
buscar la prescripción para la segunda
píldora porque así era la medicación
creo que duró ocho horas náuseas y
vomitar dolores sangrado diarrea
algunas veces todas suceden al mismo
tiempo si quiero ser madre pero hice un
aborto porque quiero ser una buena madre
al estar lista lo considere
y no me arrepiento para nada esta es una
difícil como ha sido tu percepción de tu
imagen corporal cómo ha cambiado quería
lucir embarazada temía que no se notara
mi embarazo por estar gorda en
definitiva es difícil al ver mi barriga
y ver la piel que cuelga
y el extraño aumento de peso en
distintas áreas que es muy difícil
perder durante mi adolescencia tuve un
trastorno alimenticio me llevó a ser
hospitalizada muchas veces era muy
difícil ver cómo mi cuerpo crea algo tan
hermoso y tan mágico para mí y con
sentirme avergonzada y estar fuera de
control y porque de eso se trata un
trastorno alimenticio maneja y controla
todo en tu vida luego de mi embarazo era
aún más desafiante es mi responsabilidad
asegurarme de que mi hija se alimente
bien y no dejar que la parte física
interfiera en que me asegure de que debo
estar cuidando y nutriendo a mi hija te
arrepientes de embarazarte ni siquiera
un poco nunca me arrepentí incluso
cuando me enteré nunca pensé esto es un
error
del padre no me arrepiento del embarazo
creo que es extraño porque esperaba algo
como te arrepientes de abortar pero te
arrepientes de estar embarazada nunca me
habían preguntado eso amo tanto a mi
hijo creo que es lo mejor que me ha
pasado y creo que ser una madre joven es
para mi la verdad no lo querría de otra
forma lo amo tuve tantas emociones y
luego otras no tan buenas tipo ahora que
voy a hacer mis amigos dejarán de
hablarme porque todos son muy religiosos
que suena triste porque yo también lo
soy pero cuando les dije que perdí el
bebé estaban porque no nos dijiste antes
habríamos hecho el baby shower la ropa y
los regalos creo que tal vez si en ese
tiempo habría dicho oh por dios claro
que sí ojalá nunca me hubiese embarazado
pero ahora más que nunca estoy al tanto
de que estoy aquí para empatizar mejor y
ser compasiva hacia otras personas y
creo que me sucedió por una razón y no
me arrepiento que es algo que deseas
haber aprendido antes de la educación
sexual desearía haber sabido mucho más
sobre los anticonceptivos y lo fácil que
es embarazarse y desearía haber
aprendido antes sobre sexo
y desearía que fuese más como una
conversación del día a día cómo se habla
de fútbol en lugar de por dios
relaciones sexuales saben como si
estuviese mal lo que aprendí en mi
adolescencia fue que sin importar lo que
dijera mi mamá yo haría lo que quería de
todas formas y era a sus espaldas lo que
lo hacía más peligroso para mí mi meta
es que mis hijos confíen en mí cuando se
trate de cosas así aún no sé cómo voy a
lograr eso solo sé que quiero que mi
hogar sea muy abierto para conversar
suscríbete a jubilee para más educación
sexual quieres aparecer en un vídeo
suscríbete a nuestro newsletter de
castings jubilee media puntocom envía
preguntas para nuevos episodios
jubilee media síguenos y jubilee media
sexto punto jubilee
[Música]